Oups, je crois bien je suis tombé
sur un os et pasn'importe lequel :
un crâne de tricératops, daté
de 66 millions d'années.
Je suis dansla galerie de paléontologie
au Muséumnational d'Histoire naturelle de Paris.
Vousavez vu ces cornes ?
Elles lui permettaient de sedéfendre
contre le fameux tyrannosaure.
Alors, 66millions d'années,
c'est pas jeune.
Ça date tellement que c'est à se demander
commentles scientifiques ont fait
pour déterminer
un âge aussi canonique.
Allez ! Suivez moi.
On vacreuser cette histoire.
Toi, tu restes ici hein.
Un fossile c'est rare, très rare même.
Lorsqu’un organisme vivant meurt,
ses tissues se dégradent naturellement.
Et il ne reste plus aucune trace
quelques mois après.
Mais il peut arriver que cet organisme
se conserve avec le temps
et quecertaines parties
dures des tissus,
comme les os ou les dents,
se fossilisent.
C'est ce qui estarrivé à cette ammonite,
a ce trilobite ou encore à ce dinosaure.
Emprisonnés
dans le solde l'époque,
ces fossiles deviennent aussi durs
que la roche qui les entoure
et qui lesprotège.
Un fossile et la roche
dans laquelleon le retrouve,
des millions d'années plus tard,
sont donc intimement liés.
Ils ont commencé à seformer ensemble,
à la même époque.
Celle où vivaitencore l'animal,
autrement dit la couche de sol
et le fossile ont le même âge.
Le sous-sol, comme surcette maquette,
forme une sorte de millefeuille,
un empilement de strates.
Les couches les plusrécentes se trouvant
logiquement en surface,
les plus anciennes en profondeur.
En creusant,les paléontologues
remonte le temps.
Quand ils font des fouilles
et qu'ils découvrent un fossile,
ils commencent par situer les couches
les unes par rapport aux autres
pour déterminer l'âge de lacouche
dans laquelle se trouve le fossile.
Et ils font ça au pif ?
Évidemment non.
En étudiant les solssur la planète,
ils ont bâti une échelle
des temps géologiques.
Quand ils trouvent un fossile,
ce dernierappartient donc à priori
on temps géologiques de la strate
dans laquelle se trouve le fossile,
cequi permet d'avoir une idée
de l'époque à laquellevivait l'animal.
Seulement, cette époque peut
s'étirer sur des dizaines de millions d'années.
Le Paléogène par exemple s'étire entre
moins 65 et moins 33 millions d'années.
Or jevous rappelle que
notre crâne de tricératops, parexemple,
est daté de moins
66 millions d'années.
Alors comment font-ils ?
Eh bien pour comprendre, on varetourner
au Muséum national d'Histoire naturelle.
Voici une gangue à l'intérieur
de laquelle setrouve le fossile
que l'on souhaite dater.
À l'intérieur de cette gangue,
de cette roche,
onva trouver d'autres fossiles
qui vont donner de nouvelles indications aux experts.
Finalement, lespaléontologues
travaillent un peu comme des détectives.
Élémentaire mon cher ...
c'est comment vous déjà?
En grattant on peut trouver des squelettes
de petits rongeurs, des coquillages, des pollens
dontcertains sont typiques
de certaines périodes géologiques référencées.
En se basant sur leur stadede développement
par rapport à l'évolution connuedes êtres vivants,
les scientifiques affinent
doncencore l'âge des fossiles.
C'est donc en faisantparler plusieurs témoins
qu'ils déterminentl'âge d'un fossile,
en l'occurrence 23 millions d'années pour celui ci.
Bien conservé pour son âge.
Bon, il existe un autre moyen
pour dater certains fossile,
la radio chronologie.
Allez, on retourne à l'atelier.
Dans la nature, certains atomes,
des grains de matière, sont dits"instables".
Ils se désintègrent naturellement
et se transforment en un autre élément.
Un atome A, parexemple,
devient un atome B.
On parle de couples d'atomes "père/fils".
C'est ce qu'on appelle
laradioactivité.
Mais pas de panique,
celle ci n'est pas dangereuse.
Ces atomes sont réglés
comme unehorloge.
Les scientifiques savent précisément
en combien de temps et dans quelles proportions
ils se transforment au fil du temps.
On sait par exemple, que dans une roche,
en 1000 ans, 50% desatomes A
se transforment en atome B.
Et ça, c'est très pratique parce qu'il suffit de déterminer
laproportion d'atomes "père" et d'atomes "fils"
et on sait précisément le temps qui s'est écoulé
depuisle début de la désintégration.
La plus connue de ces méthodes de datation
utilise la désintégrationdu carbone 14.
Je suis sûr que vous en avez déjà entendu parler.
Elle a été mise au point en 1949
par l'américain Willard Franck Libby
qui areçu un prix Nobel pour ses travaux.
Et c'estvrai que cette méthode de datation
a rendu de grands services à l'humanité
en permettant demieux comprendre
notre histoire, avec un grand"H".
Le carbone 14 permet de dater directement et de
manière absolue tous les fossiles récents.
Les os,les dents, les crottes qu'on appelle
coprolithesquand elles sont fossilisées,
le bois ou mêmele charbon de bois
comme cela a été fait pourles peintures de la grotte Chauvet
qu'on a pudater à 33 000 ans pour les plus anciennes.
Lecarbone 14 est présent
partout sur la planète :
dans l'air que nous respirons,
dans l'eau que nousbuvons.
Tous les tissus des organismes vivants en contiennent,
il s’y désintègre mais est renouvelé en permanence.
Quand un organisme meurt, le carbone 14 qu'il contient
continue de se désintégrer mais n’est plus renouvelé.
Il se transforme en azote 14.
On sait qu'au bout de 5730 ans,
la moitié des atomes de carbone 14 se sont désintégrés.
C'est ce qu'onappelle la "demi-vie" du carbone 14.
À partir de là,en analysant
un échantillon d'os ou de dent
et en mesurant la proportion de carbone 14,
eh bien on peut savoir précisément combien de temps s'est
écoulé depuis la mort du fossile qu'il faut dater.
Avec le carbone 14, les scientifiques peuvent
dater des fossiles jusqu'à 50 000ans
comme ce mammouth qui vivait,
il y a grossomodo, 49 000 ans.
Au delà, l'élément n'est pas assez
présent dans la matière.
Du coup, le carbone 14n'est d'aucune utilité
pour une grande partie des fossiles qui se trouvent ici.
Pour ce genrede fossiles,
il s'agit d'un mammifère marin
qui vivait il y a un peu plus de 35 millions d'années,
on le voit ici dans sa position dynamique,
c'est la dernière mise en place du muséum.
Et bienles scientifiques peuvent
utiliser d'autresduos d'atomes père/fils :
potassium-argon, rubidium-strontium
ou encore uranium-plomb.
Ces atomes ont des demi-vies beaucoup plus longues
qui sechiffrent en millions d'années.
Mais dans ce cas,ce n'est pas le fossile
en lui même que l'on essaye de dater
mais plutôt les roches environnantes, en général, des roches volcaniques quand ily en a.
Une petite carie là.
Faudra aller chez le dentiste.
Alors toi comment ça va ?
On s'occupe biende toi, ici ?
Ils sont gentils les gens avec toi ?
Ça te fait combien déjà ?
45 millions d'années!
Ça fait un sacré gâteau d'anniversaire, hein.
Je comprends que ta chambre
soit aussi grande.
Allez, on va te laisser te reposer.
À bientôt !